I think if you are a true food lover,
you are a healthy eater.
Well,
first of all,
the term Foodie is completely ridiculous
because for someone,
when you meet somebody and they say,
I really love to eat.
I think the appropriate answer is who
doesn't?
So I mean,
look around.
Who's you know,
who's not a food lover?
Everybody's a food lover.
The question is,
do we responsibly do eat for your own
benefit to you?
We fear planets benefit and do you eat
the best food possible?
If the answer to all of those things is
yes,
then you're eating well.
If you're eating,
you know if your style of eating is bad
for your body,
if your style of eating it's bad for the
planet,
then you are not really eating good
food.
You're eating lousy food and there's,
as we know,
there's plenty of lousy food around
the principled,
the principled way to eat.
If you were going to say,
I want to eat entirely for my own
benefit,
I want to eat entirely for the benefit
of the planet.
I want to eat in the most responsible
way possible to minimize my carbon
footprint,
to minimize my impact overall,
to minimize my effect on animals.
You would be a Vegan.
That's the bottom line.
The veganism is the most principled way
to eat.
That there is from the perspective of
your own body,
from the perspective of the planet,
from the perspective of animals.
Very few people are going to be vegans.
Let's be real.
So,
um,
what's next?
I mean,
on the one hand you have vegans and on
the other hand you have people who eat
whatever they feel like eating.
There's a middle ground.
The problem with the way most Americans
eat right now is that we are about as
far from veganism as we could be.
So if Egan would get 100% of his or her
calories from plants,
most Americans get 90% of their calories
from processed food,
junk food,
and animal products.
So the goal,
I think is to move in the direction of
eating more unprocessed plant food than
we do now.
And everybody's got a different starting
place.
If you eat 20 cheeseburgers a week or
the equivalent,
you might look at eating 15
cheeseburgers or weak or the equivalent.
If you're eating 15 you might look at
eating 10 and so on.
And I think if people think about what's
best for their body,
what's best for the planet,
the answer is eating unprocessed plant
food and then think about how can I eat
more of that stuff at the expense of me,
which was,
you know,
which was the question.
But also at the expensive processed food
and junk food.
The idea is to eat as many of them
processed plants as you can.
What are plants,
plants or vegetables,
fruits,
legumes,
which means beans,
nuts and seeds.
Um,
what am I leaving out?
I think that's about it.
So the,
the idea is to eat as many unprocessed
plants as you possibly can and to eat
those instead of eating processed foods,
junk foods,
and animal products.
What works for me,
what's worked for me for just about
three years now.
It works for me is to eat very,
very strict diet of plants only and
unprocessed plants only from the time I
wake up in the morning until dinner
time,
so from the time I wake up until roughly
dark,
I eat a lot of fruit.
I eat a lot of vegetables,
I eat some whole grains and sometimes I
have some beans and that's pretty much
it.
And then at night I eat whatever I want
and that's the,
which includes meat and which includes
wine and which includes pasta and bread
and stuff like that.
That's a huge change for me.
I think that if you think of your diet
as a seesaw with the,
you know the animal products,
the process through the junk food on the
heavy side as it is for most people and
the unprocessed plants on the light side
as it is for most people.
I think for me,
my cso went from looking something like
this to looking something like this.
I think that to the extent other people
can eat that way,
they will have a,
have a lesser impact on the planet,
improve their health,
probably lose weight,
feel better.
Think I just saw it.
It changed the way because if some of
the things we've been talking about
here,
one is that I,
I recognize that um,
one of the highest contributors to
greenhouse gases and global warming is
the,
is the industrial production of
livestock.
So I decided,
okay,
that was one good reason to eat less
meat.
The other good reasons he lets me is
that I was in my mid fifties and my
health wasn't what it used to be.
So I was overweight,
I had bad knees,
I had sleep apnea,
I had high cholesterol,
I had high blood sugar or borderline
high blood sugar.
I think that's enough.
So,
um,
I decided
to change my diet and it's,
it's so obvious to everyone who pays any
attention to nutrition at all,
that if you want to be healthier,
the way to do that is,
you know,
as I've already said,
is to eat fewer animal products and eat
less processed and junk food.
So I started to do that and,
and it worked.
I lost 35 pounds,
um,
gained five of them back,
but hey,
uh,
slept,
sleep apnea went away.
I slept better,
my knees bothered me much less.
In fact,
I ran the New York marathon last year.
Um,
my cholesterol is back to normal and my
blood sugar is back to normal.
So it all worked.
And it's not a coincidence.
I mean,
no one would say it was a coincidence,
actually not.
Um,
there's some things I don't like,
but I think that it's important to
recognize that there's no sort of
single,
I mean,
arsenic and cyanide aside,
there's not really a single ingredient
that's going to outright kill you.
I mean,
there's actually some evidence that a
single can of soda can trigger diabetes,
but there's not a lot of eps evidence
about that.
In general.
One ingredient,
one little kind of food,
one one meal,
one day,
even one week.
That's not what's determinant of your
overall health or of your impact on the
planet.
What determines is your overall diet,
and if it's moving in the right
direction,
which for most Americans is towards
plants and away from animal products and
processed foods,
then I think,
you know,
hip,
hurray,
you're,
you know,
that's the way to go.